êtes vous préoccupé dit quelque chose
m'a fait sursauter une ombre il faut
savoir que cet endroit décombres
craquements et grincements calmer votre
imagination débordante cela vaut mieux
je désire simplement qu'on me fasse bon
accueil à partir de maintenant je veux
que cet endroit ne respire que l'amitié
l'amour et la chaleur la chaleur voilà
qui est parfait pour commencer
thomas ce ton épouse est gelée bouillon
bien sûr pardonnez moi mon temps et
commençons par allumer un feu que vous
faire couler un bachelor au début lourds
sera rouge à cause de l'argile mais elle
deviendra vite clair et lucide quand ce
sera possible pourrait vous me donnez un
double des clés s'il vous plaît ce n'est
pas utile par dont certaines parties du
manoir sont à éviter
je vous accompagnerai dans les pièces le
temps de vous habituer si vous jugez
qu'il vous faut les gens préfèrent un
double
oui